how did the opportunity come to you to
be on Celebrity Big Brother you know
what one day my manager called me and
said I have something interesting for
you I'm like okay and this could be if
you go one or two ways yes and then he
told me well what do you think about
being on Big Brother I thought he was
kidding yeah I was like wait what but
then it was like an immediate decision
like really horse yes no are you a fan
of the show have you ever seen the show
before though I have I'm not like a
die-hard yeah and where I like watched
all 20 seasons however I do remember
when it came out I mean it's crazy that
for what season 22 technically the
second season of Celebrity Big Brother
which is insane so it's been on for like
ever ever does it scare you to go into a
house full of celebrities and you cannot
get out you have no cell phone I'm
actually looking forward to it
really to really be like disconnected
from coz everything that I do revolves
around my phone like I need my phone to
work I'm it's just like a constant kind
of device that you're always kind of
checking or looking at or basically
you're accessible to everybody so I'm
really looking forward to that aspect
but then also you know it's gonna be
definitely interesting what is your
biggest fear as you enter the house
being away from my husband yes
me and him work together as well so if
anything that's probably gonna be an
advantage of mine because he's like you
know holding down the fort and running
everything so I know that everything is
good yeah but I think that's my biggest
fear is just like missing him too much
where it affects my game and I don't
want it to affect my game and how does
that work when people are married do you
get to place a phone call everyday do
you get to text like ha absolutely zero
zero contact nothing no phones no
newspapers no TV no movies no music it's
the real deal Holyfield how competitive
for you oh my god it's in my blood I'm
the youngest of all boys so growing up
it was just like constantly trying to
beat them so that you know I could be
the best my husband and I get in fights
because he's like dude I'm not competing
against you this isn't even a
competition like relax yeah it's just in
me I'm very very competitive so I
definitely am going in ready to go guns
are blazing
so people who go on the regular Big
Brother they go they compete maybe they
went some money maybe they get a little
15 minutes of fame and then they kind of
go back to their regular lives for the
Celebrity Big Brother it's a whole
different thing and so are you worried
that you might do something that could
hurt your career
are you excited at the prospect of maybe
gaining more fans I don't think I could
do anything I mean I take that back you
definitely can do anything but I come
from reality TV from total divas and
then being in WWE yeah so I think going
into the house it's one of those things
of just like letting my fan base grow
even more and really let them experience
kind of what I do on a daily basis cuz
people can check in 24/7 online yeah
they could watch you which is bananas
like I don't think that's really set in
the fact that I mean my mom I don't know
for the next 30 days she's gonna macing
me be glued to her computer watching the
live feeds it's gonna be so weird and
what happens if you have a major
conflict with a celebrity though another
celeb whoo I don't know do you just like
body slam here we go body slam no
there's no physical contact oh they
already told you that I already told oh
they didn't tell everyone they only told
you yeah actually yeah you won't be
doing any headlocks or none of that I
don't know it'll be interesting how I
handle actual confrontation with someone
because it has to go down yeah it really
does because at the end of the day
somebody has to be put up on the block
and evicted
yeah so some stars found it too tough to
stay on Celebrity Big Brother and sent
themselves home is there any world in
which you send yourself on I don't think
so I honestly can sit here today and say
even if it kills me I'm not a quitter so
I'm staying until the end okay now we
have seen showmance this happen on the
show you are a married lady as I am how
are you gonna deal with hot men living
with them you've been married so it's
like you're used to this one you know
your husband worried at all if you look
up my husband and take a little peek at
him yeah I think you'll know that he's
just fine I don't think he's worried at
all if anything it's interesting I don't
know
I'm pretty lucky like I like what I have
did you reach out to any of your
celebrity friends that were on season 1
for advice you know what I did not I
know I really wanted to kind of go in
with a clean slate and you really take
the whole experience for what it is
because Celebrity Big Brother and Big
Brother all in the same even if you have
a strategy it's like out the door as at
the moment you walk in and meet who
you're dealing with because everybody
has different personalities
the challenges are super crazy you know
it doesn't matter if you're super
physically fit or anything they're
literally everyone's on the same playing
field so any strategy that you think
that you have going in yeah it's gonna
get kind of twisted the food inside the
house can be hard if you lose you might
be eating slop I know that you are a
physical athlete and you take a lot of
pride and care of your body are you
ready to eat slop I'm not that's the one
thing I I mean oh no the food situation
I mean I was watching season 20 and one
of the guys had to eat just a nasty
amount of ham and I'm like oh my god I
would literally be throwing that up
because just how many times this ham
situation got delivered to the house
like I hope that doesn't happen and in
this season because when it comes to
like trying to put some food down I
think my gag reflex is gonna be on and
poppin real quick
competing on reality shows like Dancing
with the Stars or celebrity survivor or
this can really like break someone's
career out even more you mean you
already have a massive career but are
you is there any dream that you're
hoping the exposure of like this massive
show could push you to you know what I
mean I'm very much about like global
domination and I want to put my hand in
everything from movies I just wrapped my
current TV show right now so if I can
continue to just grow in that
entertainment field and continue to do
more TV more movies then I think that's
like the jackpot what's your strategy
for winning Celebrity Big Brother so my
strategy going in is for the first
couple challenges I'm gonna just try to
lay low and try not to really stick out
like a target
even though it's gonna be really hard
for me because I'm so competitive that
I'm just gonna want to win just for my
own ego to try to you know let these men
know like this lady's here to play but
if anybody watched celebrity the first
season shannon elizabeth played way too
hard out the gate and she was amazing if
anything I think she should have
advanced so much further but she showed
that she is a true competitor and she
was winning things left and right so I
mean she had a 16 letter word for pete's
sake like come on
comment down down bring it down and not
bring yourself to a3 exactly what are
you gonna do with a $250,000 oh my gosh
I technically need to build like a front
gate for our house okay so that is one
thing I don't know probably take my
family on a nice trip there's a ton of
us so it's very rare that we all get
together so I think that would be one of
the the main things that I would love to
do is just like get us all together
there obviously and married so all my
nieces and nephews and everything and
really have a nice little trip little
trip yeah boom okay well good luck thank
you and I need a white Ford Raptor oh
yeah I have to my husband has a black
one yeah and I can't get out of it I
steal it all the time I gotta have
matching ones it's just it's a fantastic
car well now you have to win I know how
to show America yeah this is what it
looks like driving a Ford Roth exactly
well God now that you said that I'm
really rooting for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]